Hi my name is Sachin Duggal and I am the Chief
Executive and President of a company called
[inaudible] and one of the technology pioneers
in 2009. So role models are very important
because ultimately the create and element
of [inaudible] society at large and in the
Middle East you have people that are disruptive,
but positive disruption and I think a good
example is [inaudible] who ultimately is going
to have the best role models Middle East region
has. Someone that has that sort of passions
but also that sort of outward thinking in
terms of what she's doing for education both
for children and especially for young girls.
Role models also create idols for the younger
generation of people to look up to and ultimately
people they want to be like. That's very important
in an economy that's growing as fast and is
as diverse as the Middle East is and so ultimately
the role model mechanism as such allows people,
number one, to move forward in a direction
where they have someone to look to; number
two, try an attribute or copy some of the
attributes of the role model, and then finally
you'll see new generations of role models
coming out because ultimately great leaders
are ones that have followed others in the
past.